all right the first up she is a
filmmaker whose latest documentary
citizen floor is nominated for an Oscar
and premieres on HBO February 23rd Laura
Patris hey are you doing great to meet
you I'm a big admirer thank you you're a
very brave woman and you deserve this
Oscar I think it's a fantastic movie
it's kind of a it's like a reality
thriller I mean we see thrillers all the
time in the movies but this is a real
one this happens in real time citizen 4
is Edward Snowden mmhmm yeah it's the
story of him contacting me and sending
me emails and us exchanging emails for
many months and then meeting in Hong
Kong with Clint Green right I mean what
we're seeing I think people all remember
from a couple of years ago when Edward
Snowden was front-page news but this is
what we're seeing in the weeks before
that but what goes on in the hotel rooms
the meeting between you and Glenn Gloria
gray involved Glenn Greenwald - mm-hmm
and I gotta say I mean you guys are just
ballsy because you are hitting the
biggest hornet's nest in the world
mm-hmm the United States military
industrial complex and living to tell
about it
yeah I mean actually I didn't think I'd
be sitting here to talk about Academy
Award nomination I thought right a lot
of other risks that we that we were
facing before we went to Hong Kong but
but you know luckily um you know things
worked out and and so those the film
tells the story about first my being
contacted by Snowden and then and then
being in the hotel room most of the film
happens in the hotel right with plan and
and Snowden said that you know you
wondered why he selected you and he told
you well really the government selected
you that's because you had made films
before that got on their radar right you
were being harassed right right yeah
that's pretty badly
it was pretty bad I mean I made a film
about the Iraq war and after I released
that film I started being stopped at the
US border I was put on a secret watch
list and was detained every time I
returned to United States which happened
over 40 times over the course of many
years and what would happen is I would
be traveling internationally the plane
would land and then they would do Border
Patrol or passport and
direction as people were getting off the
plane so every time I flew
internationally border agents would be
at the at the at the plane and to to
check borders and then I would be taken
away in questioned about where I'd been
and traveled so that went on for six
years and and so it you know in a
strange way it actually you know
prepared me to to do the reporting on
the Snowden and NSA material because I
became very good at you know protecting
source material and and look people can
agree or disagree on Edward Snowden in
his place in history and what he's doing
and being a leaker and whether those
secrets were damaging I think when you
watch this film you come away I mean it
would be hard-pressed not to come away
with the few conclusions about him one
he's sincere he's not doing this for any
other reason than he really thinks that
this is the right thing to do for his
country and he's quite he's quite a
charismatic leading man for a movie
isn't he he is actually I mean the big
surprise for me and Glenn when we got to
Hong Kong we expected to meet somebody
in his 60s who was nearing the end of
his career and not to meet somebody so
young but I think in retrospect it makes
a lot of sense him and here's somebody
grew up with the internet and and was
really I was an act of conscience to say
like the things that are happening what
the government's doing spying [ __ ] if
they make a fiction version I mean
Channing Tatum Zac Efron I mean I could
I could see that but okay so he's
sincere he's also proved to be right
about a lot of this and the proof of
that is that we've had a lot of
government hearings about this mm-hmm
and in fact they voted on one to really
cut back on the NSA's activities it got
it passed the house almost passed the
Senate and I say almost it got fifty
eight votes it's only in this crazy
world we have with with the cloture
thing that they you know you can you can
lose with fifty eight votes so obviously
his point wasn't that far off the mark
and I gotta say again the balls and also
Glenn Greenwald I mean I've had my
differences with him but he's got a set
on him too you'd do this because if it
goes wrong and it still could mm-hmm I
mean you could be god knows what could
happen to you we know what the United
States government is capable of oh yeah
well we know that they've been going
after whistleblowers and sources and
journalists so you had Jim risin
the New York Times who's here so that's
been their playbook to go after people
who expose illegalities but yeah there's
a lot of courage in the room for sure if
I was going to be on the frontlines
those would be you know I'd want to be
there with you you still talk to Snowden
I'm still in touch with him yeah
cuz the last frame in the movie is just
from a long shot so we don't know
exactly where he is but it's Russia
right and his girlfriend is with him
they're making spaghetti mm-hmm
it looks like it's not that bad now yeah
I mean is she you know to her credit um
went there to be with him because she
you know loves him and wants to support
him so there at one point in the movie
he says you know they probably will get
me but the point of this is that it's
like a Hydra seven more people will
spring up and do what I did
but will they is my question well I mean
we do live in a society that doesn't
even care about this issue or their own
privacy I mean here's the thing I think
like in the years after 9/11 I think
we've seen a moral vacuum I think the
government hasn't come forward and that
we've had citizens who've come forward
as whistleblowers so we had Chelsea
Manning formerly Bradley Manning who
came forward to expose things and people
thought nobody's gonna come forward
after after what happened to her and
then in Edward Snowden came forward so I
think it's people who see things that
they think are wrong and that the that
in a democracy we should know what the
government's doing but it shouldn't all
happen in secret and that you shouldn't
have secret laws that impact all of us
that we don't know about what you think
about what Obama's doing cuz he was
asked about Stoughton he said I don't
think he's a patriot and he then he went
on to say that hey you know what a lot
of the stuff that he was talking about I
was gonna do but it seems like it really
wasn't gonna happen without this know
this certainly not it wouldn't have
happened with without Snowden coming
forward Obama also promised to close
Guantanamo Guantanamo stay that that's
not his fault
that's a congressional thing uh uh he
could have made it happen he had I mean
he's a democratic I mean they had the
the house and the Senate they couldn't
made it happen I disagree with you on
that but but IIIi don't understand why
he is perhaps the worst president we've
had on clamping down on the press
I mean he's used the Espionage Act more
than any other
president right yeah no that's it's it's
more than any other president I think
it's nine times nine people being
charged on the Espionage Act and many
journalists being put under
investigation for doing their job which
is to hold it what would you do if you
were president I mean you you must admit
that the government needs to keep some
secrets there are bad people out there
right I mean what is the right line so
if I were president I would do if I'd
close Guantanamo I'd have Commission's
to talk about torture I
what about leakers about people who want
a leak thing I mean there are people who
actually are defending us and they are
spies we need certain spies we need
intelligence I mean where is the line I
mean I think the problem is this sort of
use of classification to hide things
from the public that shouldn't be hidden
from the public and that's that that's
the issue
Snowden wouldn't I mean nobody people
aren't like lining up to become
whistleblowers I mean there's a lot of
risks and so I think that we should we
in a democracy we should have more
transparency we should not be doing
things that impact all of us in secret
all right well I hope you win the Oscar
stay out of jail all right let's clean
up